moi je vais vous dire vous me posez la
question de qu'est-ce que nous sommes
prêts à faire je voudrais dire que nous
sommes très fiers de ce que nous avons
fait nous sommes très fiers d'avoir
construit un réseau qui est
manifestement considéré comme le
meilleur réseau autoroutier du monde et
il suffit de voyager en Europe pour le
constater il suffit d'aller voir en
Belgique des sociétés des autoroutes
qu'il faute de péage ne sont plus
entretenus il suffit de faire le tour de
l'Europe pour constater que ce modèle
nous a donné un réseau autoroutier qui
est remarquable le seul pays d'Europe
qui a un excellent réseau d'autoroute
comparable c'est la Grèce pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'ils ont fait
comme nous ils ont monté le financement
de leurs autoroutes en concession donc
ce système a construit un réseau qui est
manifestement de bonne qualité quand on
le regarde
quand on l'évalue avec les indicateurs
de suivi contractuels personne ne
conteste la qualité du travail qui a été
fait lorsqu'on regarde la satisfaction
des clients et quand on regarde les
indices de satisfaction tels qui sont
mesurées année après année par un
institut de sondage qui est qui est
piloté par l'État on a un niveau de
satisfaction qui est entre 8 et 9 sur 10
bon je ne peux que me contenter de le
constater